Hey, it's me Destin, I just got home from work. Ignore the thunderstorm in the background
But a couple of things I'd like to do after a long day at work is--the first is I find my wife and plant a big kiss on her.
and then I take my boots off
That's what I like to do
So, I wanna tell you something cool that happened today
YouTube has entered me into a contest called the 'YouTube on the Rise contest'
It's a contest for people who have a lot less than 100,000 subscribers and I probably have around 9000 subscribers
and I got them from various experiments
I've done with SmarterEveryDay so
anyway I'd really like to win this
contest. I was gonna tell you why
I've got two reasons down the hall. They're
in this room here on the left
and I have one more reason but let's see
what
my reasons are doing. "What are you doing?!"
[Giggling]
How did you get up there?!
[Laughing]
Good girl! Alright, let's go outside.
With all these toys, why are you playing with a box?
Do you know why?
Why?
Because boxes are awesome!
Alright, so anyway, sorry about that.  Those are two reasons why I do my youtube channel
because what I do is
I am saving up money for my
children's education
every time somebody watches a video
ultimately, in the long run, it ends up
getting closer to
my children being smart. So the
other day I asked my children on the way home
what they want to be when they grow up so I can know what I'm saving the money for
and the response I got was not what I expected
What what do you guys wanna be when you grow up?
[Unclear], what do you wanna be when you
grow up?"
[Unclear]
What?
An ice cream girl.
An ice cream girl? Little boy what
do you want to be when you grow up?
[Unclear]
A dancing hotdog? [Laughs]
Who am I to stand in the way of my son's dream of becoming a dancing hotdog.
I mean really.
And who are you to stand in the way his dream of becoming a dancing hot dog?
so please speak...Wait
[Giggles]
So this is what I'd like you to do, if you don't mind, um, if you would
go to this website, it's the YouTube blog page
and it's called the "On the Rise Video
Contest" and if you'd vote for "destinws2"
which is my channel name
which is Smarter Every Day, if you'd
vote for that I'd really appreciate it
and there's a lotta other good people out
there if you don't like my stuff I can understand
you can vote for them. If we wanna be smart
about this, if you really do like the stuff
the smart way to handle this is not
only you vote, but you get your
friends to vote too
that'd be really cool. I'm not cute, I can't
sing and all that kinda stuff and
I'm not great at video
but I do know science and I want other
people to have the same passion for Science that I do
but anyway if you would please vote
I would appreciate it.
There's a bunch of other videos that I've already shot that I haven't edited.
I shot rockets in the smallest country in Africa
in-front of a school of young Muslim girls
to promote science education
that was pretty cool
we also did a a minor surgery
in Africa on the fly
I have nothing to offer no incentives
just me
Alright guys it's bedtime
y'all got a book? you know sry
Allright
[Child] ... story...
mmm, let's read
hey, little girl what does daddy expect of you
[Unclear]
We really. really need more
dancing hot dogs in the world